bonsoir kirill vous êtes à erevan y
at-il toujours des manifestants dans les
rues ce soir bonsoir magali et bien oui
effectivement les rassemblements se
poursuivent à erevan la capitale
arménienne aujourd'hui entre 1500 et
2000 personnes s'étaient retrouvées sur
la place de la liberté à proximité de
l'opéra rassemblement plutôt
qu'allemands pas de débordements puisque
cela entre cinq et dix personnes
interpellées par les forces de l'ordre
selon nos sources il semblerait que les
erevan est plutôt que de chercher une
quelconque confrontation avec les forces
de l'ordre étaient plutôt descendus dans
les rues pour crier leur désarroi leur
incompréhension après la décision par le
premier ministre nicolas pas de xi'an de
signer l'accord de cessez-le-feu avec
bakou sous la médiation de moscou les
manifestants scandaient notamment le
slogan pas de xi'an traître et considère
en effet qu'il s'agit d'une trahison
d'un abandon du haut karabagh par les
autorités j'ai eu l'occasion par exemple
de discuter avec un chauffeur de taxi
qui était de très bonne humeur très
jovial et lorsque je lui ai demandé son
avis sur la situation sa mine est devenu
directement grave il m'a dit c'est d'une
tristesse absolue et nous avons honte
nous les arméniens c'est donc un
sentiment honte dont il m'a parlé
pourtant le premier ministre a fait
savoir que la décision du cessez le feu
n'était pas une capitulation mais
qu'elle avait été prise en tenant compte
de facteurs complexes dans le but de
préserver la sécurité du peuple arménien
une sécurité qui dans le haut-karabagh
sera désormais assurée par moscou le
président russe vladimir poutine s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui à ce sujet et selon
lui est bien en signant cet accord
le pire a été évité je vous propose de
l'écouter conformément à la déclaration
le contingent russe des forces du
maintien de la paix est déployée le long
de la ligne de contact et le long du
soi-disant corridor de latchine il est à
noter que la région du haut karabagh
fait face à de graves problèmes
humanitaires qu on vient de nous
présenter à l'issue des combats
le nombre des victimes notamment parmi
les civils à dépasser 4000 personnes
plus de 8000 personnes sont blessées
selon différentes sources
il y a des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés l'infrastructure civile et de
nombreux sites culturels ont été
détruits afin d'aider les habitants de
la région dans la résolution des
problèmes les plus pertinents j'estime
nécessaire de créer un centre
interministériel d'intervention
humanitaire et vous l'avez compris
magali ce n'est pas pour autant que les
arméniens ici à lire evans accepte cette
décision puisque de nouveaux
rassemblements sont prévus dans les
jours à venir
merci beaucoup kirill pour toutes ces
précisions kirill coty coche en direct
des revan en arménie